cinnamon dude's kid where am I
you're in a box can wearing the creative
world wow my god is so easy my god you
can just go create it but there's a
reason very creative came a challenge
you can you challenged me that's right I
challenge you in a creative battle my
god create battle weakness creativity
that's dry for once I'm gonna put now
was a square what is this what's this
dork where jump are you died I think
that I don't know that's possible your
dad created damn girl you're just so bad
at minecraft I can never find okay well
first off how do I open the creative me
because I've never ever cheated all
right oh wait let me see how you did so
I think space or what that does not
space okay oh god maybe you have to type
creative create them hard didn't work
professional my craft layers oh oh you
press e oh now I can describe the
electric how this is awesome do what you
like trip bro okay you want are
something cool yeah show me come bra
damn I'm rich I can do anything
what breathe breath wait this is not
what we're doing by the way but look at
this wow yeah yeah that is actually
pretty cool yeah
I am a cinnamon toast cane
all right that's not easy to do this
this is not why we're here we're gonna
pick a theme we'll pick it together
whoever can build something best Twitter
will decide Twitter poll and based on
the theme we get two minutes to build
something hopefully that's not too
little and the winner wins yeah okay
yeah so we gotta build stuff maybe we
should maybe we should forget theme each
right okay yeah yeah I'm figuring this
out as we go what is this it was the
play but game I should push it then stop
dying we need to play minecraft
what should the third first theme be I
don't know what was the first thing my
birthday recently uh-huh right now is
just old age you can't be sick in
Minecraft Jesus Christ
actually dying guys this is so sad
Kenny's actually dead in Minecraft are
you ready to bail yeah finally hocked a
loogie yep I'm good epic okay wait maybe
we should make it the vision so we know
where each side is okay okay okay you
ready I'm ready what's the first thing
we should make okay we have two minutes
the theme is alien go wait I gotta pick
up my I'm gonna win Ken we're gonna win
two minutes are you keep up with the
time oh yeah I had a timer look all
right and the loser has to tweet from
the other person's account so no no yeah
yeah yeah we're doing this again this is
serious this is what minecraft is all
about how do you activate a beacon a
beacon you need to answer metal in it
enter a metal what does that mean right
I can't make up for you being bad at
Minecraft all right look you have to
activate your beacon yourself
I'm little icky yeah you are stop
looking okay
and we're almost at two minutes oh good
okay you ready
time's up time's up time's up three what
two one we do the same thing what bra -
mocking your mom has gonorrhea yep okay
okay okay all right
oh my god I guess we have to take a
screenshot and ask get out of the frame
so they know it's not you I like yours
though I think yours wins for sure look
at you two being simple you but I didn't
see the booty can adding that that's
extra points oh yeah okay I'm just gonna
say I won this one because I can't be
bothered to ask people about man all
right you get to pick the next theme
okay okay okay
my camera's frozen okay I'm I'm back at
it or what happened to my camera what
are you doing
you can't still work on it yeah I broke
it down and I was like let me put it
back in to say I say you can go back and
like look back at him okay all right
you picked the theme okay clear off your
bar here you know throw your crap out
because you keep using all this ah come
on we're gonna be limited on this one
all right all right there's always my
favorite thing in Minecraft you just
like puke out stuff the best part right
no the only thing you can have is a
bucket of water
wait what what are these rules a bucket
of water
uh-huh okay a bucket of lava
and we have to make don't bear look
don't you feel like oh my god this is
gonna be the best Kabul Sun Ken I'm so
glad you picked this thing because
finally you're gonna eat your words this
is how I wanted to make my cobblestone
generate the first time I did it oh yeah
yeah oh wow wow it's so beautiful
do you hear that Ken that's cobblestone
being generated something you wouldn't
know what it sounds like I understand
because you never generate it look up
concentrate over here okay yeah I can
tell small brain people needs to
concentrate while making big brain for
other people just use me it just comes
natural excuse me it just comes natural
I think what kind of some people make
cobblestone generators other people make
art can well we did the same thing I'm
changing up right now shut up this is
terrible but that a okay okay a real one
then a real one okay okay a real one
yeah you just do that and that I mean
[Music]
look at that oh wait we do this loser
did work Oh God - Sara babe me yeah okay
cookin my game clock is ticking Bob on
the family I know it's hard today
I need to down somewhere yeah Bing bong
Bing Bing bong Bing bong that night
oh wow it's uh
oh I can whip up a just say it Ken just
say it
apologize never apologize never maybe
it's because I've spent like oh I spent
a lot more time he's actually trying
guys like I can't pick it back it's
actually like theme 10 okay it's correct
next theme yeah yeah
minecraft girlfriend oh my god you see
thing alright see my girlfriend
you get 30 seconds to prep items okay
girlfriend he's in pink for sure
the theme is my girlfriend three two one
go go go go okay okay oh god this is
important because if she's watching this
in the future I obviously want to make
sure I'd do her justice I'm getting a
little rowdy in here this is oh sorry
Marcia but it's gonna be tough one
you're married now though oh no you
can't have girlfriends oh no you can
always have a side chick everyone knows
that I'm joking how does a joke my [ __ ]
oh my god this is awful
yeah this is your ideal girlfriend right
yeah yeah yeah she woman she she will
come alive god this is awful I need more
time ken I went to ambitious oh you went
to big huh yeah if she ceases and she's
displeased my god forbid anyone if I
displeased with anyone did displeases
okay every done I guess I have where I
went out of time oh my god Lisa's got a
hat on
okay she's got Kate whoa oh that's
burner point you are those legs
mmm-hmm what am I looking at here look
at all right so right here you got the
holy place I thought it was legs you
pray here I guess it's still and it
can't be the way family friendly
he's got cake she's got ten freakin
cakes Brown who freaking cake not much
is happening on their back end Bay look
okay ambitious you word I turn around
and I see this I want her to be crying
it out had time for one is this how you
waifu well this is how when she finds
out that I'm already married you know I
can't there it is you know that's a sad
reality yeah I'll play one for you too
this is so sick this is that this my
microphone which she sees me alright
next challenge I think you won that one
yeah got one alright next theme my nose
so I'm dying so I get to pick this one
right this is mom yeah yeah yeah your
your talent I see I see I've seen
several posts about Minecraft about when
computing power plays a jacksepticeye
it's like you guys are getting along
they were a pleasure to meet Oh skater
we'll just scream at each other so um
yeah yeah yeah it's my jacket later just
wrote me yeah green he doesn't even have
green anymore believe it
and then pasty white skin okay I wonder
if I can cooperate some more aesthetic
elements in my jacksepticeye what else
does he like Irish and alcohol potatoes
why would potatoes mm-hmm
I'm ready are you ready I get ready as
I'll ever be
here we go okay ready - one
jacksepticeye here we go I'm sorry jack
oh man when Jack sees this he's gonna
wish it was born in Minecraft as he
wishes lived in Minecraft yeah man
don't we all I do every day I'm just
like wow I'm already feeling green hair
cliche it's like it's almost not even
funny
almost I got some techniques in this one
yeah yeah what kind of technique you
using these like the bob ross technique
where i'm bob rising this one i think
you're gonna be impressed oh yeah yeah
yeah
I'll still I'll do his a man bunch so
it's like somewhat accurate hey give the
man vine oh my god emeritus oh I'm into
this one yeah yeah oh you going all the
way oh yeah I'm all the way baby
time's up what stop what but I'm not
done okay do you want to finish it up
I'm done well let me decide it today
times okay okay ready three two one
those and every potatoes are all over
the place in front of is definitely Jack
now here's one now it's markiplier well
I figured from like the large head in
the statue you'd be able to figure it
out right mark we're sorry you're not
crying look now he has water boobs yeah
nice that that's definitely more
lactation mm-hmm you actually have
nothing to say about my glorious
creation I really don't have
what are these teeth right here it's you
just asked and Steve it's is that's
Irish teeth is this cocaine are you
saying stop this is definitely him
uh-huh uh-huh I can every time I look at
him now I'm just gonna see jacksepticeye
I think you really just nailed the
personality and really got like the
aspect of what makes jacksepticeye
jacksepticeye and you really
differentiate it so much from the other
one as well I'm gonna go ahead and say
that you what I don't worry potatoes no
let's go bars boy oh boy yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna say you won that one because
it was so good Wow I'll take it next
theme is going to be since we've done
other we done a Minecraft girlfriend we
done erm I've got boyfriend
self-portrait self-portrait this is
gonna be easy I'm so around the time
already - ten out of ten Ken what
already - we talking about Mariah you're
gonna regret being so bad of minecrafter
- watching bra bra bra okay all right
now the best part
god I hope I have time oh my god don't
have enough time to do this is all crap
sword crap Bonus Time
I understand okay the race against time
it's too hard can I understand it is I
had a big idea and I was like this that
is not gonna work so I have to change it
up this all right maybe this one we can
have a little bit more time one okay
that seem fair to you because I need
more time I
I need more time for this masterpiece
I'm messing up everything what material
did I use everything relies on this okay
okay I got it I got it hey son oh hey
did I uh okay I'll let you finish
actually you know what all my I might
make even more stuff then if I have more
time yeah go ahead
sumbitches okay okay you proud of it
yeah yeah really good okay finished ah
shoot all right I guess I'll have okay
do you wanna watch my first cuz I think
here's something turnaround game oh my
god first we got the legs of course very
proportionate then we have my fanny pack
yes always active and you know i like to
write you whenever I'm pooping yeah
every single time really tell me all
about how your pooping and this is what
it allow you can see it witness it I
gotta I gotta I gotta fix something on
this though because these definitely
definitely see ya money yes detail yeah
mom's very much different than you I
don't know how to do that stuff
good job on that that's pretty late
thank you thank you all right what do we
got here oh oh oh look at from the top
Wow okay I think I know what this
alright here we go
Oh what what is this me walk you through
it okay okay that's kind of cute yeah
yeah this is me is my little face here
uh-huh uh-huh face this is the sky
up here this little sunray this is
actually a portrait right yeah and your
mermaid yeah yeah I'm swimming the ocean
but I've been stabbed in the heart
oh is that what it is oh no why what
happened can you know what happened you
know what happened back in the second
episode but you go you get back here
don't you run away from me oh yeah my
way what happened in this second
everyone the third and the third node I
want you to tell me when I'm on them
myself Padre yes ken please take a seat
yeah what happened hi yeah not myself on
fire and jumped off the level instead of
going into the water on the sky blocks
episode and everybody made fun of me and
the community stabbed me in the heart
this is the sort of YouTube and that's
my heart you know it is I know how it is
I think you win for a pity pity point no
way look at that thing look back it in
this you wanna get in it oh yeah I ran
out of poop this is so sad this is
firing empty now no I I do like your
pics light all right one more we down
their selves but we haven't done any
channel there oh yes you're ready for
this again with you oh I'm out of ideas
all right here we go ready I'm ready
here we go oh man I'm they done skin
color in Minecraft yet it's kind of
weird well what color skin color
BRR that's so deep I'm getting good at
this now I feel like yeah that's not too
bad huh not too shabby makes me laugh
alright so you can't complain about what
what can I complain about nothing what
are you doing over there
nothing
I got more volume to film yeah what
methane methane god so hard I mean cuz
I'm so beautiful it's hard to in capture
someone who looks as good as I do but
also as bad as I do at the same time
okay I think I'm that like there's a
beautiful person somewhere inside of me
I'd have a little mail yet alright I'm
done
really all right you ready to turn I'm
ready to turn three two one look at it
oh wow is something white and I didn't
have a lot of time okay we have my ears
now this is all the American flag let me
fix it okay that's better that's about
it awesome very good job thank you thank
you thank you even thank you all right
let me there we go
that word somewhere how do I take a
thumbnail of that right muscles falling
downwards they are they are in your
fanny pack is leaking I don't know what
happened to it I'd have this the best
look I like I like how uh how tall is
stature you know I'll level right here
for me I'm looking across yeah I did it
proportionate I knew yeah man
alright it's been that was fun let let
us know in the comments which one you
think is the winner yeah and that alien
though we don't make
cobblestone a different cobblestone
generators what do you mean oh there's
some cobblestone oh they even make it II
Oh like the big ones is a little bit
it's like we didn't actually test them
to see if they work but anyway it's fun
yeah it's working
check out Ken before he dives on YouTube
and that is yoke lighters that we want
us to do this again I will see you next
time
well you haven't tried to pursue Malita
City after 50 million outros much now
just now it's still relevant just down a
bit